members of The Writers Guild Union
marched on picket lines outside Amazon
studios in Los Angeles they want better
compensation better residual payments
for their work when it is broadcast or
streamed and minimum Staffing
requirements we're asking for a
reasonable amount of the profits that
they that the studios make on our work
it would to meet our total demands it
would only take two percent of the
profit they make on our work
some of the effects will be immediate
production will cease on popular late
night talk shows that rely on up to the
minute political satire nevertheless
actors and talk show hosts expressed
support for the guild we have a lot of
uh staff and crew that will be affected
by this you know but you know they got
to get a fair deal so uh yeah I'll do
whatever I can to support them other
impacts will be felt the longer the
strike goes on over time the production
pipeline will start to dry up some
studios and networks have stockpiled
scripts and programs but they won't last
forever viewers may see more Reliance on
unscripted reality TV shows foreign
the trade Association that represents
the entertainment Giants said it had
offered writers what it called generous
increases in compensation
Guild officials are sounding the alarm
about Advanced artificial intelligence
taking writers jobs and demanded
restrictions on its use AI is a threat
to everybody in the business and I think
that's part of the reason that we have
the support of all the other major
unions if they can replace human beings
who do this work the economy is going to
collapse there's just no reason to do
that and the companies refuse to even
discuss AI knock-on effects of the
writer's strike will be felt by Caterers
electricians drivers makeup artists and
many more trades economists estimate the
strike will cost the economy up to 30
million dollars per day
Rob Reynolds Al Jazeera Los Angeles